Dr peterson was the party.
Thank you both for being here today.
Um,
when political scientists have studied
is to solitary and regimes.
I'm sorry,
I'm going to move this a little bit.
Just feel weird.
Totalitarian regimes.
I've studied.
I tried to look at the Iranian
revolution and the Islamic Republic of
Iran and I've argued how the Shia Islam
that is teached in the Islamic republic
is very close to a totalitarian regime,
but now I live in a country where my
ideas are considered controversial.
If you believe in God,
if you believe in family,
if you believe in having responsibility
and traditional values,
I feel ostracized by the community here.
I came from UC University of Calgary
over there.
I didn't feel this way.
There was more welcoming.
Here I feel marginalized and I do feel
alone and when I see this,
it disgusts me that here they can do
this,
but I couldn't go to their events,
do anything.
I'd have to shut up the disciplinary
committee for me,
but for them they can break windows to
God knows how old this building is and
it's okay for them to do that.
So my question to you is now being here,
experiencing this,
I'm starting to second guess that maybe
the totalitarian Islamic regime that I
was so,
you know,
talking about and critical of back in
Iran isn't so bad when I have a choice
between having to be here and be
oppressed and be there and at least have
my ideas be okay with the regime.
So my argument is if this free speech
and the arguments you guys are making
here,
it doesn't work,
would that not be the next step for
people to go towards totalitarianism?
If dialogue fails,
then isn't force of arms the only thing
left?
How can people compromise when they
don't want to talk,
when they want to yell?
Thank you.
I think you make a very good point.
I don't think we should fool ourselves.
This is about force and it is a.
it's almost a dare to suggest that that
certain elements are not allowed to
enforce their view of the world and that
speaking contrary to it,
isn't that a front to those values and
they won't shut you down.
I mean that,
that,
that is what is at stake.
We,
we are,
we are no longer really in a situation
where this will all be resolved through
sort of gentle,
reasonable civil dialogue that,
that happens on the side,
but it's not real anymore.
It's not really where the fight is
happening.
This is a,
an imposition of the force of the state
and it is skewed,
it is skewed a certain way and we are
getting to the point where a certain
kind of language or certain kinds of
dialogue is,
is approved and all right and a certain
kind is not.
And that is the campaign that is going
on to,
this is all part of.
And I have to say that,
that your presence here and your
endorsement of this kind of event is the
kind of thing that has the major
pushback to trend,
but the trend
is continuing and is a very dangerous
one.
And uh,
this is,
uh,
a difficult moment in the life of this
country.
Would you,
would you say Jordan?
So,
so some,
some comments about,
about your career.
Let's say.
Okay,
so you're a young mountain.
And you've got lots of years ahead of
you,
so you know,
you want to prepare for the war,
not the battle,
right,
okay.
Because there's going to be many battles
for you personally and perhaps
politically and all of that.
And so you want to make yourself as
articulate and educated as you can and
you want to have patients.
I would say that there is no cause for
despair,
you know,
I believe that the,
the,
the people who are attempting to
radicalize our society and to transform
it into a battleground of identity
politics are in the distinct minority.
And I think that I think that there is
no reason to assume that we can't push
the devil back into the,
into the bottle,
so to speak,
to push the genie back into the bottle.
And so don't despair.
Now from a personal perspective,
it's like we've got lots of things to
learn and you've got lots of things to
say and to write and you're going to
find now and then that you were imposed
upon in a manner that you don't find
tolerable,
right?
You think,
I can't live like this,
right?
It's going to distress you in,
well then,
then you've come across your moral
conundrum,
right?
It's specific to you and then you have
to.
That's when you have to grow up and
think strategically.
It's like you decide,
are you willing to live under those
conditions?
If you're not,
then you develop a strategy.
It's like,
okay,
I'm going to.
I'm going to fight this.
I'm going to fight it carefully,
intelligently,
thoughtfully on multiple fronts and I'm
not going to back down and you don't
make that decision lightly.
You know most things you should let blow
by you because there's not that much of
you and there's lots of things,
but now and then you'll find a stumbling
block that you can't get over it because
it hurts you.
It damages your soul.
That's the right way to think about it.
Well then that's the time for you to put
your education to use.
No,
and you'll be able to do that.
I mean,
you don't want to underestimate the
utility of of deep,
forthright speech.
I don't believe that anything can stand
in its way.
It have the courage of your convictions,
but don't give way to despair like this
battle is by no means over.
No,
I know meets and it isn't even obvious
that the bad guys are winning,
so to speak.
You know?
I mean here we are,
we're having this talk.
The university came out forthrightly in
favor of free speech for.
Thank you.
No one so far.
All the questions today have been
thoughtful and intelligent.
You seem like informed so like don't
underestimate your strength.
And so,
and mcmaster just published a set of
guidelines governing this sort of
behavior so that it will no longer be
acceptable to disrupt perfectly
reasonable proceedings on university
campuses
in the.
And so the,
so the discussions like this can
continue properly.
I mean there's definitely a place for a
give and take and for informed
opposition let's say,
but there's a difference between
informed opposition in child childish
grandstanding.
And I think people know the difference
between that.
So don't,
don't be desperate about it.
Pick your battles.
A little courage goes a long way,
right?
Because other people see it and
there's a.
There is I think a silent majority out
there that is silence and is scared,
but if they see courage from somebody,
they responded to it.
Well,
I think you described lawyers in a way
that appealed to me once.
He said,
I think I know that's rare,
but
you said lawyers.
I think these are the words you said
lawyers are difficult and emotionally
stable and is the combination of those
two things.
The willingness to be difficult but not
to be emotional about it.
Don't,
don't,
don't wear your emotions to the fight.
Take a step back,
engage in it.
Say what you think.
Be Courageous,
but don't get wrapped up in it.
Don't be emotional about it,
but you know,
retain your strength for the long haul.
Well,
you know,
one of the things I've learned
strategically,
and this is really worth thinking about
too,
is that when you're engaged in a public
dispute like this,
it's not obvious when things are going
your way.
You know,
you think,
well,
this protest is not such a good thing.
It's like,
I wouldn't be so sure about that.
You know,
what's happened to me in the last 18
months is that virtually every time that
I've been attacked and some of the
attacks have been quite well,
I wouldn't say brutal because we haven't
got to that thank God,
but they've certainly been,
um,
they've taken me aback.
You know,
it's not,
it's not a straightforward thing to be
in a hall with this happened at mcmaster
with 100 people yelling at you and
blaring air horns and all of that.
But that wasn't a bad thing as it turned
out because it was filmed and it was put
on Youtube and it was terrible for the
people who protested,
you know,
it wasn't good.
And so you got to detach yourself to,
you know,
if,
if you say what you think and you're
careful about it,
it's going to have some short term
effects and it's gonna have some medium
term effects and it's going to have some
longterm effects.
And one of the things that you need to
do,
I would say,
and this is an element of courage,
is you have to have faith that the
medium to longterm consequences of you
saying you have to say as clearly as
possible,
it's going to be positive and you have
to act on that supposition.
You don't know,
right?
You can't know that that's the
existential leap of faith is you can't
know,
but you act anyway.
And my experience has been that you
don't wanna.
You don't want to make judgment too
quickly because it's not always clear
when things are going your way.
So when you know you might stand up in a
class and say something that people
react negatively to eat and you might
get pilloried for that by some people,
but you never know who you're touching
in the crowd and you don't know how
that's going to unfold across time.
And then you have that might be a
defining moment in someone else's life
to watch you stand up and say what you
have to say.
So don't underestimate the power of
truth and courage really.
So
thank you.